[Music]
married
Kaitlyn Bristowe and Shawn booth are a
rare bachelor nation success story
almost three years after he proposed on
her Bachelorette finale their love is
going strong but while many wonder when
they're getting married the pair have
focused on building their relationship
and the businesses you come out of that
world right and then you have this
following and you're like what do i do
what do I do
I don't want to go back to my normal job
that's suppose about this as post about
that but I mean it's booth followed his
passion for personal training now he's
launching a fitness app and opening the
gym in Nashville where they live daily
exercises modifications it's for all
levels it's like a healthy lifestyle app
so it's in it's in the palm of your hand
you get tips and tricks and there's a
community where you can post pictures I
can go in there and chat with you guys
and Kate and I just do things that we
genuinely enjoy and that we love so it's
easy for us what do you think has been
the key to you staying together after
meeting in this weird way and after
being part of this crazy world yeah it's
it's tough I can understand why couples
break up if you're not strong enough to
handle a lot of the outside noise and
just the the concept in general it's
very easy to just call it quits and
we've obviously had a lot of bad times
but a lot of good times and I think
we've just kind of stayed humble through
it all and just put each other first and
work work on our relationship so we
always said we use the show to meet one
another yeah but yeah I mean it feels
like we're engaged but we're also taking
our time too and people always say it's
crazy that we're not married yet after
three years and I'm always like well
what's the average time frame when
somebody meets somebody - being married
right we've been engaged for three years
but we've also known each other for
three years her personality is something
that I'm very attracted to and she is
very humbled and gorgeous and funny and
has all those qualities that I look for
in a woman